yeah welcome to this new video I'm a
different kind of game today try to keep
the channel varied with the different
kinds of content and this is some game
that that I played yeah in
correspondence chess which i rarely play
but I started playing on a couple of
weeks ago on yeah due to an invitation
by not a very prominent youtube channel
owner um yeah kingscrusher you probably
know him on trifon his scotum
correspondence chess of a chessboard
dotnet and never played down but he said
okay let's let's try it you can you can
play yeah sort of casual correspondence
chess there it's not like highly
official with some I don't know
worldwide federation or something is
just some casual games with lots of time
that you have for your moves so on I
played a couple of games then this is
one game that I played against them a
pretty high rated opponent on the server
I'm not quite sure how it compares to
two other ratings but on the server it's
a pretty good players Katya maxime vs
I'm not quite sure um yeah but it was an
interesting game and I wanted to show it
also because it showcases some pretty
interesting line against the Sicilian so
on let's get ahead Jim a play deform try
to experiment a bit in those casual
games usually don't play for but in this
game I tried it I also take note of
caught that the chimes on the side are
just nonsense we had five days to move
maximum but it usually was one move per
day something like this or sometimes bit
quicker the first couple of moves we
will play quicker alrighty played the
Sicilian
and we went for the open in Sicilian itm
clay d6 the scavenging and variation or
haven Ingham maybe um yeah this is a
very yea rather old kind of line in the
Sicilian even played in the 1920s or
even before that and yeah black tries to
set up a flexible poor information here
with the both those pawns d 6 & e6 and
he intends to play it on the queenside
later with them something like a 6b five
or advanced one of those pawns according
to the concrete situation where we're
different kinds of answers some may be
necessary black black is very flexible
here yeah him why just got a very
principled move and this is G father
Karras attack and here very often it is
said that Jung the carrots attack
actually deters people from playing on
the thus giving and the Pure's given
again this is also why Garry Kasparov
always played e6 a six-year the night
off and after almost all kinds of moves
by white played e6 to transfer bows back
into the disc evening and set up at
having avoided the carers yeah in the
game though opponent allowed before but
I didn't play it because I wanted to try
out a classical kind of setup with
Bishop e2 I always like this quiet setup
which has been tested extensively in the
world championship matches like a
boyfriend Casper off cup of playing
white at the time is so played avani
form and cup of almost always played
this slow system against the setup which
has been yet developed by Russian no
legend if in Gila in the 60s 50s even
and this system is some pretty much how
I played it here but should be two
castles and then F form so wyd doesn't
really try to go for an ultra sharp
approach here with long castles and the
porn store but he completed some
development and tries to UM yeah play
with pieces and pawns in the centres
it's marvel yeah and it's more focused
on playing the center then on the flanks
with her with the porn star um in this
position on one key point is if wide to
play safe or if he doesn't I could have
played instead of F for you a form to
prevent the b5 booth but it's not the
problem at the moment and the mover
played their form yeah it doesn't
prevent v5 completely block could play
it but it's not particularly good a firm
black would play b5 now there's this
Bishop f3 IDM and Freddie five this is
some really problem after this kind of
stuff black gum ki loses material
already he's got nothin better than this
kind of line and I'm just an exchange up
not so much to show for it so b5 is not
a problem at the moment he just canceled
played Bishop e3 to complete the
development and black plate 96 this
point B 5 is also out that by a bishop
f3 it's still not a great move and here
played Queen you wanted this is one of
the main lines of this position why just
got various alternatives at some a very
young complex kind of opening where I
move forward as am i important what can
also play this a form move to really
prevent be 54 forever so to say he can
still play
play this one king h 1 f 1 king edge one
often go well together it's very hard to
do without this move in the long run so
lots of alternatives I decided on
Queenie one the idea of Queenie one is
to quickly get the Queen to g3 where to
put some pressure on black skin and it
also connects the rooks of course so on
this is some good move black now I'm
plate Quincy 7 which pretty much fits
into this whole setup Queen g3 Bishop to
d7 and template King edge one I think
you cannot really yeah play without this
move alright with your black plain be
five so I never played a four to prevent
this didn't want to spend the time on
this but here it done it's just a
problem that black is threatening before
and in this way also taxi form so i need
to do something about that and played a
three to prevent this concrete idea yeah
this is some still own rather than own
theoretical position and here black
plate them a rather ram bullfighter had
to look it up of course I'm not an
expert on this he played rook f2 eh I'm
this kind of root placement is not
uncommon in none in this is so lien of
course quite often the rookies some well
placed on the aid it allows them the
bridge bishop here to draw back and
probably at some point might support the
five break so this is not uncommon the
main move this move had a problem though
i'll show it that's what I played in the
game which leads to a huge problems for
black the main line on here is actually
night XD for Bishop takes and Bishop c6
I think a very sensible looking line
where this Bishop
is activated I'm still why just got this
pressure on g7 so you don't need to
protect you form you can just play a
move like this between be seven and we
should be three now blue form this
looked some all very logical now wide
some probably most promising lunes night
to d1 not taking but naughty one the
idea being to use the night on the King
side and this kind of line and then why
deserve probably somewhere somewhere
between equal and the slight advantage
to white maybe but this is so the main
line which one should be it should be
okay for black he played this rook fe8
them and in this position white of
course them has more than one move from
available you could think of various
rook moves rook d1 or okie one but a
very important point in this kind of
structure where those pawns are oops now
this none of the night meant those pawns
this the center you for an air form you
always need to check the advances of the
pawns like II five or f5 and then in
fact in this position I am able to play
a five and this is some really very
strong the problem is also that the
rookie aid um yeah now blocks the square
for the knight on f6 f6 night doesn't
really have a good square to go to and
you know what should black do now he
took only five which is the best move
you can also look at other things I'm an
alternative slight d5 it's not it's not
playable about 95 it gets answered by a
very typical trick which you are yeah
should try to
remember in a way because this very
typical this the some disparado night 95
is very strong threatening a check made
black takes it doesn't have much choice
then the d5 night is some is lost yeah
this leads to a disaster really white um
just enters blacks position and this
kind of stuff is just winning night XD
seven ships e6 black is completely tied
down with his pieces I don't even have
for something sacrificed to get this
position it's just completely
overwhelming without any material
deficit so he cannot answer 95 and yay
council cannot take here because there's
a neat little trick this at first
doesn't look so awful but this is a
problem threatening made threatening the
Queen and if the Queen takes which is
yeah basically the only move then you
can take with check and some sort of
when the rook for just a pawn yeah and
you're just the rook up so this was also
not working so he had to take on e5 and
after this I can actually just recapture
and the point is on ya black cannot take
with the Queen because this is also very
typical maneuver now the queen is
hanging but if you take here i have this
intermediate check and i'm just a piece
up so this is also a trick to remember
so what should you do this night doesn't
have oops this night why doesn't a zone
sorry i did something wrong here this
night it doesn't have have a square to
go to so he needs to take e five there's
not much not much else and now is in a
very dangerous pin this night is some is
now in really am in lots of danger
I played Bishop h6 year which is think
the best move threatening this made yeah
and he cannot go on a g6 simply because
of the spin queen is lost so he must
play g6 and now they have 69 is also not
protected anymore by am by the pawn i
play now Bishop f4 the most straight
forward movement is possible that here
maybe there even was something better um
the move I'm thinking about is rook a to
you one this is probably better the
thing as some yeah black is still in
this pin and he really doesn't have a
good move to get rid of this problem
what should he play if you are for
instance play let's say rook c8 to to
cover the Queen to allow this night to
move then white place this move again
just like in the game but now I already
have the rook here Bishop f4 we should
be six and now the funny move Bishop d1
the only square where the bishop bum ya
can go where the night cannot take and
now he's really in huge trouble how
should he keep the peace the the only
way basically am to even continue the
game is not see for Bishop d 626 Queen D
696 and then rook takes f6 we are first
nothing you think is just a piece it's
not one hundred percent clear though
this kind of stuff and like well we'll
get second porn after which your pawn
structure and peace coordination is a
bit it's a bit broken um it should be it
should be a winning for white in a way
but it's not completely completely clear
cut I didn't see this though
and I just focus on Bishop f4 which
looks strong okay one might be strong
one but then okay this leads to an
advantage but the other line might be
somewhat stronger okay and here's no
choice Bishop t6 and here played a rook
a 2d one the alternative was rook ae-1
again which can lead to very similar
positions for instance rook c8 assem the
same as before um here he would have an
alternative they win 95 with the
possible continuation of night f5 again
this IDM 9f 59 f 496 quite them quite
complicated this this stuff Queen takes
and Queen takes yeah auntie is still in
the pin for instance this and this and
the pin is still an issue he needs to go
F 6 cm to even keep the peace and after
f6 I can i can take here take here and
we get to this position where white is
some also quite clearly better but the
game continuation I even like more this
is very good though brooke a one was
some 81 was was a decent alternative but
i won't drop 81 it just looked more yeah
more to the point to me to attack this
this Bishop the defender of of the light
which keeps blacks position together he
played them Group A to C eight now
covering the Queen certainly not a bad
move um it's really tricky for black
just for example if you would like win
b8 this way also protecting the Queen
white would have the nice short nights
six just very strong we takes it then
white can even take on d 626 Bishop g5
Quincy five and queen air for now we see
that this night is completely completely
doomed if he moves that Queen f7 is
checkmate so something like this
something he cannot move this piece and
this means i will get it i will get it
back with the huge position you need to
play this even and now Bishop f6 and
white is just winning with the with two
pieces for the rook and this this is
king position it's just just terrible
with this bishop so on it's already very
tricky i think we guys yet is basically
the only move to really continue this
and now i just played night to be three
the night back threatening rook takes t6
and this again pretty much forces black
sound so he doesn't have an alternative
he cannot move the bishop he cannot move
the Queen without losing the night and
if you move the night then you are you
simply have this problem of bishop d6
and this piece is also hanging this was
the positive effect of Bishop h6 this
was really important to get fixed the
kingside weekend so he doesn't ever move
he needs to play the movie played in the
game and this is 925 yeah and here I
looked at this a little bit deeper and
decided to ya to go form I'm quite a
huge transformation of the position now
um I now took on d5 but with the rook
and this is in fact rather strong I
think it transposes after a very long
forced line two
to a very good end game and it's all
pretty much force now black needs to
take and now 95 the problem with the
Snyder's white also threatens Knight to
f6 he now played quindi aid we can look
really what happens if black for
instance captures here then white has
the very strong of 94 protecting the
bishop attacking the Queen and where
should it go let's say he grabs on b2
then white has the very strong check on
on a fade and black now gets completely
completely destroyed let's say king of
eight bishops 16 kinky 795 check looking
back to end and this kind of position is
just yeah we won't he won't last long
here however thanks is only seven and if
he if he takes him just even a check
made in chapel of the loose so you see
rookie 727 checkmate yeah very a very
nice line so I'm he couldn't couldn't
grab on c2 so he couldn't take on c2
there's not much else down then so Queen
d8 oops Queen d8 the only move at this
point and now White has the simple move
Bishop g5 attacking the Queen and it
doesn't have a square all those squares
are controlled by white knights so I'm
very nice looking kind of move he needs
to go there should be seven now on the
tricky move we should an 80 g form it's
also not really working it looks nice
though
still fails to to the smooth Queen here
and just taking on d7 and why this
winning we've got two minor pieces for
the rook this is mrs. hanging and if the
night moves then there's Queen and
Knight to f6 check so this is just lost
for black you cannot play Knight to g4
so at the end there's just one move
Bishop e7 after which White has the
simple answer takes and queen it wrong
and now it's a very very nasty-looking
pin what should black play you played
the strongest moves now Queen to e8 the
normal looking move knight c6 yeah in
fact losers instantly to Bishop f3 and
then now black gum simply has no way to
defend against those threats taking on
c6 and taking on his heaven there's just
no move if you go Quinn to the eighth
then white even has the very strong
reply Bishop to d5 threatening to take
on e seven and then on f7 and it's just
it's just over black gum like his toast
here you can try to block this this f7
point but then white just place this
move also getting this idea into the mix
and this is just curtains black loses he
must play what he actually played in the
game this Queenie Aiden's the ideas i
took now and there's not much else then
there's a knight to c6 sort of yeah
changing the move order now the bishop
is hanging and e2 Bishop is also hanging
so why doesn't have mother else he needs
to move the bishop and now we get the
piece back so it's a very long line
which is pretty much forced from move 19
and
26 now draw rookie one and this is the
point of all this if black now would
take the pawn I just have this simple
move and it's yeah mate mate yeah and
two moves you can check the Queen but
then it's squeegees have made so it
cannot take here and I'm also
threatening this stuff so it's just this
move nothing else yeah net here you kind
of like to continue the tech but that's
not really am a promising attacking
continuation so on I opted for the end
game and just exchanged yeah this is
some an interesting position to to look
at white um doesn't have any extra
material it's a it's just five points
each and its opposite colored bishops
but this there's a big difference here
this is just one of the best bishops
I've seen for a long time it's just so
nicely placed on f6 restricting blacks
King it's an can easily be made at one
point with let's say a look here are all
like this on the back rank and so this
Bishop is just a tremendous piece his
bone structure is completely wrecked on
the King side this is not normal three
pawns you will never ever get get a
passed pawn on the Kings side so this is
in fact a huge advantage in this
position and the additional problem is
it's my move and a half 95 this night is
also very strong checking the bishop
checking the pawn so on White has
conservatives advantage right into the
end game where black is very poorly
coordinated yeah he moved the
there was not much else and also
attacked the pawn so at this point it
wouldn't be a good idea to to take the
pawn black gets it back on c2 and I
thought of exchanged a very weak pawn
against the very air yeah healthy porn
so on it's better just to play c3 and
keep this pawn the arms at a five
securing the hiss a porn and now I went
rook d1 I think this is a good move with
the ideas of very probably group d 5 or
up d 6 you have these two possible entry
points for the rook at age six now yeah
the idea is to activate the king in this
way there's hardly any other possibility
how to how to activate the King this
Bishop is just so strong restricting
legs movements like loop t5 now of
taking the the bishop and possibly
attacking also these pawns on the
fifth-ranked your answer with rook e8
threatening and made here which I need
to attend to kingi one yeah and now this
piece is hanging for real so he dropped
it back yeah white um what is nice but
how to hard to continue here that's more
than then one good plan probably but
it's always a good rule of thumb if you
don't see anything super concrete then
it's often a good idea to check which
piece is not really playing and yeah
this is white skin the king is not
really contributing to the game at the
moment so it's not a bad idea to just
activate the King King f2 is a sensible
move he played before now yeah it was
difficult to to not move
them on the queenside in the long run an
alternative here was a for which you
could consider the idea being to sort of
block whites and majority but while in
fact has a simple and strong movie and a
form and this yep pretty much wins
outright a line like this is just it's
just over for black you have now this
this very neat square on c3 where the
bishop protects the b2 pawn and this is
just an enormously strong piece on on c3
and white has just night to be six and
then the a poem will run so a form also
wasn't so great he went for befall the
problem is if he doesn't do this am i
play 97 and attack this pawn so we
decided to move it anyway take stakes
and now a form yeah this is a passed
pawn and of course black needs to take
care of this pawn it's impossible to
ignore you first try to solve this King
position problem I went 97 and this is
some design to maybe drop to be six at
some point because you need this this
square this aah square to promote it and
also their ideas of Knight f6 at one
point if the bishop is moved later so a
good move to to even improve the light
position when Drew Kade and now route c5
you'll see that this this Bishop
completely dominates the night the night
cannot go anywhere it's all covered he
went to a five at the end if you go to
d8 then white simply attacks the pawn
and I know maybe he ever it's not much
of a difference and you cannot take on a
four because this piece is hanging and
let's
926 for example what yeah what can just
take it and yeah it's two pawns to
connected passes so this is why when is
985 yet you don't like the night on the
on the rim but as you saw the the other
move wasn't what so great either yeah I
wanted to use our pieces so use the king
a king III night b3 and through p5 yeah
of course here you needed to calculate
11 line that rope takes a form is not
possible here due to rugby aid and
threatening check made if black now
provides himself with some room for the
king then why just place this taking
away the g6 square and it's just rope 2
h8 next move Black has no way to prevent
this yeah you see this pieces on this
pieces are just tremendously strong so
it couldn't done really take on a form
and he played night a one with the ADM
night c22 to cover the before porn of
course I can just play rugby eight now
and simplify matters now considerably
you need to be cautious of course with
the exchanges especially with those
possible opposite colored bishops but
this is still just strong like cannot
avoid the rookie exchange otherwise he's
made on a jade so we needed to to give
okay gave a check for us it doesn't make
much of a difference and then took here
and now it's just the a porn deciding
the day played Bishop d3 a five
kingi six we should be five this is all
very understandable i guess we should be
six and Bishop c4 yeah the idea to go to
d5 covering 8 a-6 55 yeah and here it's
also a rather important point white
could could try to immediately falls
through the a porn with a move like 97
to be six and then move the pawn like a
not stop it but there's no need to
really you can simply play the move g3
here and cover the pawn no need to rush
without with this pawn you need to be a
bit cautious after the promotion of the
pawn you only have three points left and
you don't want to exchange too many
pauses might get tricky at the end so g3
is simple and good played king here and
now I'm I have a strong move 97 which
was necessary to see before the point is
if he plays king e6 what he did there's
not nothing better really I have this
Knight b6 move where it belongs anyway
and the trick is if he takes the six now
I can take g5 and the recapture needs to
quite promoting the pawn so it cannot
take the night and if you cannot take
this he needs to go here stop in the
pawn and here white can just them here
what can just win the rest of the pawns
with new flock here you can just take
can just take the rest now so I just
didn't help he played Bishop c6 and
now the bishop is attacked for real need
to remove it and the tech age six in the
meantime 91 and now you need to pay
attention it's really it's really funny
in chess here was really close to while
i was i was getting the move from 91 on
my mobile phone really and was looking
at this and yeah why not a 7 and then i
had a somewhat closer look end and
spotted that if i play a 7 now checkmate
nagi to is checkmate a really funny made
really really amazing the night has
those two squares then they have those
wrecked bones but they take away squares
and the bishop and I'm check media some
black really am managed a direct
checkmate thread in one move so on white
needs to spend one tempo yeah with with
the King moved to not get mated play 93
I'd here still I had the possibility to
play just a 7 and promote down the pawn
but it's just easier to keep more points
on the board so I played H form this
bonus is promoting anyway and you can
spend this move to prevent them yeah
more porn exchanges be three this was a
tagged after all na sebya now add term
it's close to promotion 95 and I just
promoted here because that's also a neat
little trick take stakes and if black
now he relate King at five if you would
play Knight see for now which looks
perfectly logical King e2 and takes then
White has the nice moves Knight b6 and
this night is dominated cannot go here
because of the be 69 and white is too
threatening
push up a three winning I'm winning the
piece so this is a neat little point
however still if you look at this line
you could continue this for a bit King
f5 Bishop here takes takes no sorry so
yeah I had wrong move order here takes
on be too clingy to ya tags tags k m5
Bishop em5 cakes here here you should've
6v to you should be to King edge for and
hit this line yeah you still need to
know how to mate with the night end
Lydon bishop so after really I think
nicely played game it's not necessary to
know this this elementary mate so black
could have tried that to make me show
this but ok in correspondence chess you
really should should be able to do it I
mean of course also a normal normal over
the broad chest but it getting a tricky
with 30 seconds or so on the clock
alright so this was maybe a slightly
tougher but ok I'll it would would win
king air five he played and now I get
the night back end also make sure that
94 isn't played kingi form and Bishop d6
yeah and this is quite nice if he takes
g3 now then he's independent I can just
take it and this position is winning I
get e 5 and stopped the edge porn with
King and Bishop air king and I'd so
rather easy win he played 96 because the
other one was just losing and now after
night c4 simple move
protecting all this he resigned I'm just
a piece up and I can can't play this
next yeah I think a pretty pretty
interesting game what's useful is really
in me always need to look at technical
breakthroughs in the center like this d
5 mph this is some yeah basically the
winner of the game after this it was
some just a question how white continues
and in which way he continues to play
with an advantageous position position
and yeah I only only managed to get a
clearly better end game but maybe it was
even possible to to get more in the
middle game I'm not quite sure even a
longer analysis didn't um didn't give me
a clear conclude conclusion here yeah
also if you like to play some casual
correspondence as I can recommend this
server this chess world net it's it's
free to play that you don't need to
don't need to pay and they're currently
also some promotions available so you
get some features for free which at
other times you need to pay for so check
out just what I've netted son it's nice
and it so it's for free yeah thanks for
for watching I hope you like the game
and yeah talk to you soon with new stuff